Rising 85 feet above the surface of one ocean,
and then descending again to be gently floated
on another one, ships that traverse the Panama
Canal shave nearly 8,000 miles off of their
voyage to the other side by investing a long
workday climbing up, and then going back down,
the Isthmus of Panama.
Made possible by a handful of locks, despite
the extreme expense for commercial vessels
to traverse it, about 5% of all the trade
in the entire world passes through this early
20th century engineering marvel.
Where the Canal sits, the Isthmus of Panama
is a mere 51 miles across.
Compared with the Suez Canal, which was twice
that length when first constructed in the
modern era in 1869, the shorter Panama Canal
was expected to be relatively easy to build
when first envisioned in 1879.
And, since those visionaries had successfully
completed the sea-level Suez Canal, they planned
on making the man-made waterway that would
join the Atlantic and Pacific Oceans in the
same manner (i.e., at sea-level).
Sea-level canals are precisely what the name
implies – the channels are dug sufficiently
deep that their water surfaces are the same
level as that of the bodies of water that
they join– and to accomplish this, a great
deal of earth is removed.
In the construction of the sea-level Suez
canal, approximately 600 million cubic feet
of stuff was removed from the land, and more
dredged from the adjoining bodies of water.
With that French-dug channel that joins the
Mediterranean and Red Seas taking only 10
years to complete in middle of 19th century,
many thought a similar channel across the
far-smaller Central American peninsula would
be a snap.
In one of the western world’s greatest examples
of hubris, they could not have been more wrong.
Diplomat and engineer Vicomte Ferdinand Marie
de Lesseps was instrumental in building the
Suez canal, and he led the initial work on
the Panama Canal as well.
Disease and construction delays hampered the
project, and after nearly seven years, only
a few of the hundreds of feet of excavation
necessary had been accomplished – and this
just from one part of the channel.
Yet even with these dramatic failures, it
still took de Lesseps another two years before
he agreed to consider the construction of
locks to help solve the increased elevation
in the middle, thus reducing the amount of
excavation needed between the two sea-level
sides.
But even then, the locks were intended to
be a mere temporary solution while the digging
for the sea-level passage continued.
Interestingly, the person chosen to construct
the locks was none other than Gustav Eiffel
(who built a tower in Paris the next year
for the 1889 World’s Fair), but it was already
too late for the Central American project.
Compagnie Nouvelle, the company funding the
work, went bankrupt in 1888, and de Lesseps’
died in disgrace shortly after.
Understanding the immense value such a canal
would have to the United States, President
Theodore Roosevelt committed to the construction
of the Canal, and in 1903, negotiated the
Hay-Herrán Treaty with Colombia (which owned
the canal zone at the time).
Wisely, the Columbian Senate feared the United
States would use the opportunity to seize
even greater political power in the country
and refused to ratify it.
Undeterred, the U.S. then aided a Panamanian
nationalists’ rebellion (including stopping
American-owned railroads from transporting
Colombian troops and sending the Nashville,
a U.S. warship, to protect the rebels).
On November 6, 1903, the United States recognized
the Republic of Panama.
Twelve days later, a new treaty, the Hay-Bunau-Varilla,
was signed, and it granted the U.S. permanent
and exclusive possession of the zone (in exchange
for a $10 million signing bonus, or about
$255 million today, and $250,000 annually
beginning 9 years later).
Work was slow-going over the next few years
with efforts focused on revamping the 60-year-old
railroad and improving working and living
conditions.
The locks were begun in August 1909 with the
construction of the Gatun locks (on the Atlantic
side).
Consisting of over 2 million cubic yards of
concrete, at Gatun there are three sets of
paired locks (the Canal is actually two parallel
channels that, in principle, would allow two
ships to pass in opposing directions at the
same time).
Each lock is 1,050 feet long and 110 feet
wide, and together they are placed consecutively,
like watery stair steps, to ultimately raise
(or lower) ships the 85 feet between the highest
point on land and the oceans’ surface.
As a ship enters a lock, over 25 million of
gallons of water is added to raise the boat
to a level sufficient to allow it to enter
the next lock; walls that are anywhere from
45 to 55 feet thick at the base and tapering
to just 8 feet at the top hold all of this
water in.
This process repeats twice on either side
until the ship reaches the plateau where it
sails across the isthmus toward the other
set of locks to repeat the process, but in
reverse, where water is drained to lower the
ship at each step.
On the Pacific side, there is a single lock
near the apex at Gatun Lake called the Pedro
Miguel, then two others down to the ocean
at Miraflores.
Ships enter via two-pair of large, yet relatively
lightweight and buoyant, 7-feet-thick gates
that vary in size depending on conditions.
The heaviest and tallest gates (662 tons and
82 feet high) are at Miraflores where the
tidal range varies greatly; in fact, at Miraflores,
the difference between extreme high and low
tides is so great, depending on conditions,
a boat may need to be lifted (or lowered)
as much as 64.5 feet or as little as 43 feet;
the remaining Pacific lift, at the Pedro Miguel
lock, is a consistent 31 feet.
Likewise, on the Atlantic side, the lift of
the three Gatun locks remains relatively stable
at 85 feet in total.
Remarkably, ships require only 2 feet of clearance
on each side of the Canal, such that, in the
110-foot wide area, a boat 106 feet across
may traverse – although not necessarily
without a bit of anxiety.
The maximum length of a ship allowed in the
Canal is 965 feet, and the maximum draft is
39.5 feet.
Together, these maximum specs are known as
the Panamax.
This is small by today’s standards of commercial
ships, and although some massive ocean vessels
routinely carry 18,000 containers, the largest
that can pass through the Canal will hold
less than 5,000.
To continue to remain relevant, the Panama
Canal is expanding.
To be completed in 2016, the new canal will
have a new set of locks that will be 180 feet
wide and 1,400 feet long, with the new post-Panamax
capable of ships as big as the largest that
traverse the Suez Canal today (which can handle
ships large enough to hold about 13,000 containers).
Interestingly, due to currents and other such
factors, the Pacific around Panama is on average
about eight inches (20 centimeters) higher
than the Atlantic, meaning that if a sea-level
system was dug, there would be
a significant current flowing from the Pacific
side to the Atlantic side.
Tidal currents would also present something
of a problem for
ships in this case.
If you’re wondering how much it
costs
to go through the Panama Canal, this varies
greatly depending on what you’re hauling
and the size and type of ship.
But, for ballpark reference, if you’re a
commercial ship carrying around the maximum
5,000 containers, you can expect to pay a
bit under half a million dollars when all
the fees are added up, give or take depending
on several different factors.
On the other hand, if you’re on a cruise
ship holding, say, 1,000 passengers, the cruise
company is going to be paying close to $150,000
for the short cut.
That said, if you’re just out on your own
little private boat, depending on size you
can expect to pay around $1,000-$3,000 or
so
to go from one side to
the other.